c'est des jeunes qui n'en peuvent plus a
un regard assez jeune qui n'en peuvent
plus y à nous parents mais on en fait
une base et mais un jour s'il n'ya rien
s'il n'y a aucune promesse de fait moi
je le dis franchement moi mon dossier il
n'est pas ouvert là dans le mois qui
arrive on arrive au mois du harcèlement
mon dossier n'est pas réouvert mais ça
va mal se terminer c'est ce sont les
parents qui vont finir par faire justice
eux mêmes mais on est tout un groupe là
on ne peut plus quand on voit justement
la petite gêne à voilà d'inaki qui a mis
fin à ces jours là il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça il ya une miette de moi
c'était pareil enfin on en a on en
apprend tous les mois enfin un jour
enfin ça va finir ou savait où on va
faire justice nous mêmes parce que on ne
peut on en peut plus en fait on n'en
peut plus et c'est bien possible on
passe à la télé on oui alors on est à un
tour et il n'y a strictement rien qui
avance que alors les et l'isi oui parce
que les hyérois moi juste dit moi je moi
je connais ce sujet c'est de travail ce
sujet beaucoup de victimes c'est
extrêmement douloureux
il ya deux choses dans ce que vous dites
y'a il ya le traitement judiciaire qu'on
doit avoir et puis à la création d'une
vraie école de l'empathie d'une école où
il fait bon vivre où il fait bon à
prendre et c'est là dessus que il ya
déjà des choses qui ont été faites et il
faut continuer à arrimer juan sas et le
monde des bisounours que
j'allais dire
je dire presse et la deuxième chose
aujourd'hui vous le savez sur le sur les
cas de harcèlement il n'y a pas de ya
pas de date de qualification pénale de
harcèlement scolaire ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui à vous avez le harcèlement
moral qui est un harcèlement chapeau et
puis vous avez le harcèlement au travail
donc en réalité on protège les
travailleurs et on protège pas les
enfants dans leur apprentissage
moi je fais la proposition qu'on ait une
qualification pénale de harcèlement
scolaire pourquoi ça va faire avancer
bien que ça ne suffira pas ça ne suffira
pas si à l'école il ya des choses qui ne
changent pas mais pourquoi ça fera
avancer tout simplement parce que pour
le traitement judiciaire des dossiers
quand vous allez venir porter plainte ça
sera harcèlement scolaire et ça montera
tout de suite aux procureurs et on
pourra tenir aussi des statistiques sur
le harcèlement scolaire qui sont
aujourd'hui très complices hakim al dah
mais c'est bien le cas des statistiques
mal à mes réponses
et la perte atteint steam ça fait 5 ans
et sa mère cynthia monde attend mais
l'idée prônée notera sur le que moi
quand je sens que je travaille sur le
sujet
c'est tous les jours que sa vie et
allons faire moi il désolé non mais chez
sanoma bien
subir encore ça combien de temps 10 en
cinq ans mais n'importe quoi en fait un
acte que ça soit harcèlement scolaire
opa scolaire et je m'en fous ça reste
quand même punissable par la loi ça
s'arrête là par la loi et la direction
les vallées les directeurs d'école
l'établissement devrait devrait être
puni aussi l'ami ben oui pourquoi un
directeur d'entreprise
quand il ya un problème dans une
entreprise il peut être enfin il est
puni un autre tribunal oies et un
directeur d'établissement
0h accueillant et confus quand même des
enfants mineurs et et on va pas enfin on
nous on emmène nos enfants pour qu'ils
suivent une scolarité correct et pas
pour ce faire c'est faire tuer
aujourd'hui il ya nice aujourd'hui ça
continue pour toi parce que tu avec lui
aujourd'hui
tu es souvent avec nous donc ça se passe
très bien ici c'est vrai que c'est un
bonheur de t'avoir je te le fais tu
adores étais tu vas vraiment partie de
la famille aujourd'hui tu as toujours la
boule au ventre quand tu rentres chez
toi à quand le quand je tu viens de dire
il ya un instant que tu as dit était
fini et ce que tu reprends pas espoir
maintenant j'aimerais bien de gérard hui
quand je suis avec vous mais quand je
suis pas avec vous là là je vous dis
honnêtement couche avec vous j'ai beau
m'être le serein mais les fake moi je
vous dis il est fake moi je me connais
je suis fait moi je suis pas comme ça en
fait vous mais que le sourire de base je
ne saurai pas comme ça quand je suis
fichée je me sens bien je me sens
sereine je suis en sécurité
mais en dehors je me sens aussi que je
suis enfant sécure des tapeurs toujours
tu as toujours peu mais en fait jacques
seurt ce cas on peut tomber sur
n'importe qui et dans la vie à défaut en
fait il ya quelqu'un qui peut mouvoir
dans la rue qui peut s'en charger un
couteau non mais là oui mais on reste
poli par yvan toi tu étais tu avais tu
as vécu une agression qui tu as
certainement traumatisé personnalité oui
quand on fait ses soeurs des traumatisés
choqués n'était pas la première fois oui
mais ça m'a choqué quand je crie sans la
vidéo juste pour moi c'était une
détresse parce que je pouvais je pouvais
rien faire les étables ou bien sûr
dizaine sur moi et où je pouvais rien
faire sandrine moi j'ai quelques elmo
calme où vous auriez pour yanis
aujourd'hui pour lui donne espoir
ce que je sais que vous avez une
association je sais que c'est important
pour vous donner vous essayez aussi de
de redonner espoir à des des jeunes qui
sont harcelés qu'est ce que vous lui
diriez yanis qu' il ya des gens qui sont
là pour t'aider il ya des associations
qui sont là
pour t'aider à parler aussi
et justement vous avez une question pour
erwan oui je me permette de lire puisque
d'accord les voilà
on avait quelques propositions et
justement par rapport à yanis ça ça peut
être aussi bien nous on aurait voulu
qu'en fait que ce soit une cause
nationale un script comme un projet
d'école obligatoire que
les proviseurs soit responsable et qui
est un outil de prévention doit être mis
en place dans chaque établissement
chaque victime et donc par rapport à il
ya il ya nice aussi chaque victime doit
être accompagnée pour guérir du stress
post traumatique et ça aux frais de la
collectivité et nous c'est nice c'est
notre demande ont l
habitude tous à l'heure où là c'est moi
c'est exactement mais proposition donc
assez ça c'est fait c'est pour ça hein
sandri causes naturelles tu es dans le
thé dans le thé dans le vrai puisque
c'est exactement des nounous three
journée en colère à mesa
faut savoir quand même que avant
l'amendement que j'ai fait passer sur la
loi de la confiance en 2019 le
harcèlement scolaire imaginer ça le
harcèlement scolaire n'était même pas
inscrit dans le code de l'éducation
donc on l'a fait inscrire aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on aille plus loin et ça va
exactement dans le sens de ce que vous
dites il faut qu'ils aient dans les
principes cardinaux du code de
l'éducation le droit pour chaque enfant
à une scolarité sans harcèlement et sans
violence et dire ça c'est que justement
ça garantit un certain nombre de
protections pour nos jeunes parce
qu'aujourd'hui je pense moi que même
s'il ya des éléments de de deux
programmes qui ont été mis vous parler
des programmes le programme phare qui va
être d'aider qui va être déployé dans
toutes les écoles alors ça prend du
temps parce qu'il faut le déployer dans
toutes les écoles l'idée c'est que
d'avoir dans chaque école du personnel
formé pour traiter les questions de
harcèlement parce que le harcèlement
scolaire quand on en arrive à des
solutions à des rations que c'est
judiciariser où il ya ses portes de
plein de ça veut dire que c'est déjà
trop tard c'est avant qu'il faut le
travailler et s'est cassé tout de suite
c'est quoi les délais pour que ça va
c'est quand un professeur c'est quand
quelqu'un en fait c'est ça moi moi je
dis qu'il faut que chaque personne dans
l'école chaque adulte dans l'école soit
un minimum formés pour détecter les
signaux faibles voire fouet pour voir
ceci d'accord on voit la cantine va
manger tout seul et là tout de suite on
met en place quelque chose qui marche
très bien qui s'appelle mais un jour ça
fait normal il ya eu des manques mais je
ne dis pas le contraire mais voilà
qu'elle est folle éviter ces enfants
qu'il faut faire c'est celle de
sensibilité
parce que c'est un faux rythme les
années